please welcome
alyssa milano
you i have to tell you first of all i
wish i was there so i could hug you no
but second of all like and look at us i
mean i was trying to figure out it's
been about 35 years that we've both been
in each other's
circles which is
that's exactly right and i immediately
hearken back
to a story i don't know how old we were
maybe 12
um
we were both at a carnival
at i think was at notre dame high school
in the valley
wow and you were wearing a pair of jeans
and on the butt it you would sharpie you
can look but don't touch
come on i am not kidding and i was like
i love that you're like confident to say
like i know you want to look but you're
bold which is so foretelling
of the woman you became which is but you
can't touch
and that's right you know
you
you were someone i admired too i loved
you on your show you were beautiful
uh you know the girls loved you the boys
loved you
you were having a big singing career
also simultaneously you were
you know checking a lot of boxes you
were international and then
i feel like and tell me what your
perspective on this was there was
definitely a certain point after we were
12 13 14
where i decided i wanted to change a
narrative that i wasn't a young kid
anymore
um and
sort of yeah it's it's interesting
because when i think about that time
a few first of all when i'm looking at
britney spears going through her
uh re-awakening right now on instagram i
think about
that she is doing what
what she would have done had she had
control of her life at like 18 or 19 or
20 years old right it seems like she's
going through this like
here i am which is what we were and i
kind of feel like
you know in the 90s everything was
hypersexualized
but also
for me those were the roles i was
offered like it wasn't interesting for
people to hire me to keep my clothes on
because that was just samantha miceli
for 300 episodes yeah so
i feel like i did what i had to do to
continue working as sad as as that was
it's such a different time now i mean
could you imagine any of the poison ivy
movies that we were both in we have two
i know we have okay first of all we were
both amy fisher
yes
that's true
um
and in fact i think we have clips uh oh
i'm excited me too i haven't seen this
since i'm excited okay roll the clips
i have proof
i found this in my little sister's bed
he hands these out all the time it
doesn't prove anything look okay i have
proof i found this this in her bed
i gotta say
you win on the accent there's no
question about that well that was real
okay
i'm from brooklyn so i can go into it
really easily you really when i'm pissed
and a little drunk forget it i am so new
york
when i used to
i love that
i love that and then we both decided to
double down on poison ivy
yes well you led the way thank you for
that i was really trying to prove you
know that i wasn't the little girl in et
anymore yeah but it was but i think that
was what we were we were those were the
options we were given like i always say
if i if i had the option of doing you
know poison ivy ii and beetlejuice
obviously i would have chosen
beetlejuice but those were the things
that were offered to me i auditioned for
beetlejuice and didn't get it me too me
too
god if only we had like our audition
tapes to put up side by side
and
i am happy
that
you know we are parents now ourselves um
and boy i
definitely feel a lot of the effects of
the way that i grew up in my parenting
isn't that wild
what is it like for you
well i mean my daughter's seven right
now and she
she looks a lot like i did at seven and
that's when i started working so i have
this fierce
need to protect her and give her
maybe what i felt like i was lacking
um
and it's it's pretty profound and it
really didn't my my issues of growing up
in the business really didn't
surface
um until i had my first child
and
it was because i just had this
reflection of these little people
looking back at me
and i i just i never
felt that i had that same kind of
security that hopefully i'm giving to
them
like even though my parents are
incredible
um
they're really they've been married for
55 years they're really incredible but
the industry for young people is look
we're the only industry that still
allows child labor
right
it's like entertainment industries
singers everywhere else
it is it is ruled unfair to make
children work yeah so i think there is
always that feeling of not feeling
completely safe and i have the best
circumstances with you know incredible
parents and tony and judith and
catherine just being you know incredible
role models but it was it was hard and
to go through puberty on tv
i mean
it was hard it was hard i
am amazed at what an activist you've
become i've been reading your book and
it's
just so interesting i mean
what
gave you the courage
to fight for what your right is
well thank you for for reading the book
and for the opportunity to
to answer this question because it was
when i was 15 years old there's a little
boy named ryan white
and he was hiv positive
and they kicked him out of school
because this was a time when there was
so much stigma surrounding hiv
and they made it seem like he could get
kids could get hiv from just casual
contact and he and i became friends and
he asked me to go on the phil donahue
show which just it was like the oprah
back in the day
and kiss him to prove that you couldn't
get hiv aids from casual contact
and i did and that moment it did a lot
for me um first of all it
it made my
fame make sense to me it never made
sense before that moment i wasn't
comfortable with it yep and and it just
became part of
the job almost in a way because
without it
i felt like being an actor didn't
didn't fulfill
my my soul and my being
so um yeah so that was it i was i was 15
and obviously it's changed over the
years uh you know in 2000 i lived in
south africa for three months and then i
became a unicef ambassador
and then social media happened and it
became a lot more
easy
to to
to be an activist and to be a community
organizer and to organize for issues
that i thought were important well when
i look at your body of activism it is
tireless
it is across
many different subjects and i'm really
impressed
with how much
you are invested in this and how much
you give and how much you really live
that genuine life and i commend you for
it and i have tremendous respect for the
human
and activists and mother and woman that
you have grown into and i'm so glad that
ryan white asked you to do that and your
life since then has just been very
authentic and was so excited to promote
your new upcoming book sorry not sorry
which is also the name of this very
powerful podcast that you started in
2019 and i'm in complete admiration
thank you for that
[Music]